well for the second year in a row nevada
is facing cuts to the amount of water
that we can draw from the colorado river
we do thank you for joining us here at
six o'clock i'm denise valdez and i'm
brian loftis those cuts are planned for
next year and more could be potentially
on the way
george knapp has been following this
story quite closely george live in
studio with what he has found out
basically it's a mess the colorado river
has been considered the most endangered
river in the country for two decades but
the other states in the river compact
have acted like it's no big deal instead
of preparing for this day by
implementing water conservation they've
acted like a 23-year long drought
doesn't exist
the worst drought in 1200 years has
helped make the point that the colorado
river system is in big trouble
over-allocated and under-appreciated
department of interior officials spoke
tuesday about partnerships and
cooperation among the river compact
states but to many that sounded like
wishful thinking the seven states tribes
and mexico were given two months to come
up with plans to reduce water use but
other than nevada and arizona other
partners simply weren't willing to budge
the circumstances we face will require
swift actions
and increased water conservation in
every state from every sector
we all have a responsibility to ensure
that the water we do have available is
used with maximum efficiency
and that additional conservation will
occur expeditiously but if it's going to
happen the feds will likely have to
force it southern nevada water authority
general manager john ensminger has spent
the last few years trying to nudge his
contemporaries into taking the kind of
conservation action that's left nevada
which gets the smallest amount of water
from the river in much better shape than
larger states which get humongous
allocations enzinger issued a scathing
letter on monday about the failure of
other states to come to the table in a
meaningful way he singled out what he
calls drought profiteers example the
imperial valley of southern california
as the i-team has reported that district
gets millions of acre feet of water per
year and uses much of it to grow alfalfa
a water-intensive crop that is mostly
exported to china for animal feed
ordinarily
i stay out of my neighbor's business but
when you have a math problem and eighty
percent of the water use is in
agriculture and eighty percent of that
eighty percent is for forage crops which
are largely exported it's hard not to
see how that's not part of the solution
water officials outline various
scenarios for the river system and for
lakes meat and powell based on a
24-month study and most scenarios look
fairly grim climate change makes it
unlikely there will be dramatic
turnaround in the foreseeable future if
ever the department says everything's on
the table and when asked twice about
whether they would consider draining
lake powell they didn't say no
wow well that's startling so any idea of
how big the next cut will be because
obviously other states didn't really
propose anything no so now it's going to
be imposed on them and us as well 15 to
30 percent is what we're hearing we'd
ask john ensember what he would predict
he still doesn't know but 15 to 30
percent that will hurt it'll hurt those
other big states a lot more it's going
to hurt us and we knew today's
announcement was coming so it's been
coming for a long time environmental
groups water activists spoke after this
event today and they've they basically
said we told you so they're calling for
really really active uh and progressive
kind of measures that go far beyond even
what the department of interior is
talking about all right george thanks
for that